Sue Ellen is next in South Carolina hi
Sue Ellen how are you hi guys I'm well
thank you are you better than I deserve
what's up hi new to this budgeting thing
have never bought you this before off by
needing more money I worked more and
we're trying to get right sighs I'm just
retired we made every mistake that you
can and we have $30,000 in credit card
debt so related budget and we're trying
to get to that zero point I've picked up
another job a small job and we can't we
haven't been able to get to the zero so
what I want to know is I'm thinking we
do have faith we have our 401 K and I'm
thinking we should pay off a car one of
our cars so that we have that payment
available to go into our budget how much
do you have in your 401 K well it's our
retirement fund now we have about a
hundred thousand we had much more spent
quite a bit of it would you spend it on
well this isn't the first time we've
paid off debt so if you were to take
money out of there and pay off all your
dad what's to say that you're not going
to just keep spending like you're in
Congress I'm much more committed Wow and
whether my husband and I are now working
together on this which is wonderful
thing who was the problem you're him
mostly and the freewheel but he never
wants to disappoint me you don't tell
you know so years ago continue to do it
so you're really done cuz you mean
you're gonna be broke and you're gonna
be eating dog food I know I'm done I am
done and you know what are you all on
these cars really we have two leases and
I'm trying to sell one what's your show
a bowl so well I haven't got I thought
I'm on on line to be sold on market
but I haven't got any bytes so far okay
price it and get it so let's get them
both gone and let's get rid of those
payments and then you got $30,000 in
credit card debt and a hundred thousand
dollars saved what's your household
income about forty five thousand dollars
we retired now and how old are you gosh
I'm 68 and my husband is 73 I know right
well here's the thing the reason I'm
saying is not just that you're here I
mean I wish you weren't here too but if
we use thirty thousand bucks to pay off
your out of your hundred thousand to pay
off your credit cards and we sell the
cars only get a couple junked cars to
drive which is just fine with me for
right now
you know it's gonna leave you about 50
grand because you're gonna have to pull
out enough to pay the taxes on the
thirty so you got to pull off 40 and
that's going to leave you 60 and your
total nest egg sixty thousand bucks in
your 68 and 70 years old that scares the
crud out of me but I'd rather have you
there than have credit card debt do you
own a home when you have a mortgage on
our home in South Carolina 2000 what are
you oh I am 130 okay see you're barely
paying those bills aren't you well there
isn't too bad because the taxes are so
low here mortgages the mortgage in taxes
and insurance together and about just
under 900 okay well what I would tell
you to do is to sell both cars as soon
as you can without getting in a bunch of
trouble on them and I will pull out
enough to pay off the credit cards make
sure all the credit cards are cut up and
closed and you never touch another
credit card the rest of your life well
you cannot afford to own that snakes the
snakes have bitten you you're poison in
your system do you feel it I do feel it
okay I got a rare that and so and then I
want you and your host wheat husband
who's so sweet he won't tell you know to
go through Financial Peace University
and I'm gonna pay for it because I want
you to try to put together a retirement
with dignity plan here and I think you
can do it but you're just going to watch
every little nickel every little nickel
is going to have
to behave because the dollars have
already gotten away and now we've got to
work on the nickels and so we'll help
you but you got to get out of those cars
and you got to get rid of credit card
debt you got to be on a budget so get
your every dollar app open and get get
going with it and um Kelly I'll pick up
and we'll get you into Financial Peace
University as our guest we'll take care
of you and then you call me if you get
scared and you're working on this and
you don't know what to do but you got to
stick with this Sue Ellen you don't you
don't have another shot you can't
squander this shot this is your shot
stick with it and I'll help you I'll
walk with you